(fly buzzing)
♪ The yellow sunshine... ♪
- Yimana, who Sylviane
was based on,
came to America to go to
a 2-year silent retreat.
It started to feel like
this metaphor
for the whole experience
of coming to America,
like the weirdness
of a silent retreat,
and that you're looking
to pick up on human behaviors.
Now look around
at people's props.
You should've maybe
got more pillows.
People have some other stuff
that looks cozier.
In a way, the silence in the episode
was almost like the great equalizer
because once
you took away language,
no one knew she was...
a foreigner.
Because the episode
was in silence,
you needed visual ways to explore
what was happening in her brain.
I decided that Sylviane was
going to have these weird hallucinations.
♪ Take my hand,
follow me ♪
♪ To the bay behind the sea ♪
- This episode explores the ways
we're all different,
and how that can prevent
connection sometimes.
But I think the cool thing
about this episode
is it shows much more
about how we're all alike
than how we're all different.